et l'invité des cinq dernières minutes
c'est isabelle huppert bonjour on est
absolument ravie de vous accueillir sur
le plateau du 13 heures on vous reçoit
parce que vous êtes au centre d'un
double hommage qui se déroule en ce
moment à paris
une très belle exposition de photos de
vous d'abord fait part d' immense
photographe pendant trente ans on va y
revenir dans un instant est un hommage à
la cinémathèque
ça vous fait quoi tant d'honneurs et de
reconnaissance en ce moment à paris
ça me fait plaisir et puis c'est une
manière comme une autre et pas la
moindre de parler de cinéma surtout et
de parler de photos de parler des films
c'est une bonne occasion
alors on découvre en fait en tout cas
moi je découvre votre passion pour la
photographie
parce qu'en fait pendant trente ans vous
avez demandé aux plus grands
photographes de réaliser des portraits
de vous m'aimez henry en regardant ce
livre ses portraits qui sont très beau
vraiment magnifique on est vraiment
stupéfait de voir à quel point vous
changer de visage en fonction du
photographe mais en fait il n'y a jamais
eu de projet au départ il ya eu le
hasard des rencontres il ya certains
photographes effectivement vers qui je
suis allée d'autres que j'ai rencontrés
par hasard et c'est plutôt en mettant
tout d'un coup ses photos les unes à
côté des autres que un sens est apparue
et que ce sens c'était surtout la
présence des photographes avant tout est
presque là ma disparition derrière ces
photographes et à partir du moment où
j'ai commencé à en faire j'ai eu envie
d'en faire de plus en plus à une espèce
de jeu à la fois de la profusion et la
frustration c'est un peu un jeu sans fin
et
ça m'a amusé alors on comprend bien
c'est leur regard regard des
photographes que vous défendez et vous
dites qu'il ya eu vraiment des
rencontres entre vous et eux des moments
un peu magique qui se sont passées ce
que est ce qu'il y aura quelques uns qui
vous restent en tête encore aujourd'hui
21 oui des moments surtout avec les
photographes dit humaniste parce que
finalement aussi il apparaît dans le
livre qui est un peu des groupes de
photographes qui se détache n'aurait les
humanistes elle est contemporain il ya
les photographes de mode et avec des
photographes comme edouard boubat robert
doisneau cartier-bresson ou willy ronis
s'était des promenades avant tout est la
faute aux arrivées de manière presque
accidentelle en fait on n'y pensait pas
vraiment c'est une conversation qui
trouvait son prolongement tout d'un coup
dans la photographie ou c'est comme un
silence en musique qui résonne en
fonction de ce qui a résonné avant mais
la photo c'est un peu pareil c'est tout
d'un coup quelque chose qui vient
ponctuer un échange une conversation qui
a commencé quelques instants après qui
va se poursuivre quelques instants
quelques instants avant quelques
instants après et qui se poursuit pour
nous puisque l'écossais ses superbes
photos parlons de l'hommage à la
cinémathèque
qu'est ce qui est important pour vous ce
que vous dites qui est important c'est
qu'on parle de cinéma mais en
l'occurrence là aussi c'est un hommage
qui vous est rendu à vous
personnellement oui c'est c'est serge
toubiana qui a eu l'idée de voile à 2,2
me proposer de rassembler ses films j'ai
tourné beaucoup de films c'est vrai
depuis l'activité très beau film des
films un peu dans beaucoup de pays
donc ça et puis des films qui ont été
moins vu aussi certains à leur sortie
comme par exemple les filles comme elle
fume comme une inondation qui l'a vu que
j'ai tourné en russie où les films de
werner schroeter sa mascotte relationnel
vont pouvoir les découvrir la
cinémathèque c'est l'occasion oui c'est
une raison de les revoir et puis la
cinémathèque c'est un lieu formidable
aussi c'est un lieu très très vivant le
public
on a l'impression à a changé c'est
peut-être un public plus ouvert moi
cinéphiles c'est des conditions
techniques exceptionnelles c'est une
très belle projection donc c'est vrai
que c'est agréable de revoir les films
aussi de ces deux conditions et pas
simplement en dvd ou ou à la télévision
même par exemple alors le dernier film
que vous avez tourné je crois c'est
celui de claude chabrol vous y incarnez
une juge qui pourrait ressembler à eva
joly on peut dire ça oui qui pourrait un
peu rappelé eva joly je sais pas si dans
le générique du film qui a marqué tout
soit vous semble enfin vous savez quand
vous marquez d'habitude je sais pas si
peu de chapeau elle est allée jusque là
caron oui on reconnaît clairement
certaines figures qui ont peuplé le
paysage politico judiciaire d'humilier
milieu des années 90 mais c'est pas
uniquement un film sur ça parce qu'après
tout ya envoyé spécial pour sacrifier à
alex harvey de la pop est donc un peu un
film caché à l'intérieur du film mais
aussi comment tous et toutes ces
personnes passent de la sphère publique
et la sphère privée comment le le
pouvoir a des incidences sur leur vie
privée sur leur vie intime sur leur vie
affective
voilà donc je ferme le personnage peut
rêver un peu voilà donc le film de
chabrol sort le 22 février c'est bien
cela oui il faut absolument aller donc
au couvent des cordeliers à paris
jusqu'au 22 janvier puis du 4 au 25
février parce qu'il petit hawaï a nation
pour les présentations de collections
malheureusement et qu'il faut aussi se
rendre à la cinémathèque donc pour
l'hommage qui vous y ayez rendu isabelle
huppert on vous remercie infiniment
d'être venu sur le plateau du 13 heures
c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
vous de la boire